welcome to the world of backyard science
once a year 50 or 60 amateur scientists
gather at my home from all over the
United States and every year they have
new inventions to share we have lasers
vacuum pumps 20,000 volt transformers
this might just be the best place to
learn about high-level science outside
of an MIT lab
[Music]
tucked away in lakeside Virginia is a
man who's dedicated his life to science
I've always looked at eating and
sleeping as a waste of life I could have
been reading in physics doing something
in chemistry something with my hands my
name is Richard hull I am a retired
electronics engineer I was an amateur
scientist from about eight years of age
growing up during the space race Richard
became fascinated with nuclear science
Eisenhower gave a speech before the UN
he urged the American people and the
world in general who come deeply
involved in what was going to be our
atomic future in that initial spark led
Richard to become the first amateur
scientist in the United States to build
his own fusion reactor the first time I
ever did fusion I was elated fusion is
the complex nuclear reaction that powers
the Sun and Richard recreated it in a
shed behind his house the fuser
as such requires no general license to
make because it's not considered a
dangerous technology a lot of people
look at it as the ultimate DIY would be
nice if you've welded before you're
going to be handling flammable gases in
gas lines you're going to have to do
some wiring because the fuser needs 30
and 40,000 volts and those intense
x-rays they'll certainly go through you
despite fusions complexity serious
amateur scientists like Richard are
working through their own backyard
projects so I formed a Chie s
high-energy amateur science group local
group here in Richmond we have people
from all walks of life people like
myself electronics engineer the chair of
chemistry at a local university a
janitor another one that works for
Greyhound bus rebuilding engines
we are a community collaborating with
amateur scientists and working with your
hands is what the group is all about
that's a little bit of the nitrogen
interacting with the xenon I'm
constantly searching for something that
will amaze me and that I can carry
forward so did that grow as you pulled
it out it was already under there and I
lifted it out see the high energy
amateur science group allowed me to
teach or to transfer some of my
knowledge to other people who were
thirsty for it and wanted the effort
itself is part of the thrill the
challenge and each time no matter what
happens you wind up learning something
[Music]